they say we're enemies
they say we're divided
they say we're supposed to hate each
other
but are they right
what's interesting is that they go to
the same bars
the same parties the same schools and
the same country clubs
together maybe they're on the same team
[Music]
maybe they're the enemy of course we
have differences
yes we don't agree on everything but we
have far more in common than differences
we're more alike than they want us to
believe
we all believe in freedom we all want
what's best for our kids
we all want great relationships we all
want a healthy life
we all enjoy a good meal with good
company
maybe it's time for us to not fall for
their tactics
maybe it's time for us to not be
manipulated maybe it's time for us to
realize
who has the power
and if we unite they
will no longer have the power to divide
[Music]
us
you